some art idealizes and some art focuses
on the messiness and i feel drawn to
portray the messiness
i'm most interested in the human drama
that's always where i want to start is
the eyes which is where the expression
starts which is where the emotion is
finding the moments where my characters
are trapped by their own humanity is one
of my favorite things
i think the overall message is that
humans are absurd and it's okay we're
all in this murky soup together and so
to have my work impact someone's day i
try to really remember that that's the
greatest part
my name is kendra i'm a cartoonist and
i'm on the pacific crest trail hiking
for five and a half months
my husband and i are on a journey from
the border of the united states of
mexico to the border of canada
we've gone through desert and mountains
and snow and rivers and forests and lava
rock
if you're stuck
in the back country in the snow
with her she can map and compass her way
out of anywhere
she's walked about
1820 miles in the last four months or so
and pretty much dragged me along gone
through two pairs of shoes on my third
she's incredibly smart and funny and
remarkably driven
i've almost filled up two sketchbooks
which feels like a good amount of work
for the amount of time that i've been on
the trail i have a third one on the way
i was hoping that walking the trail
would focus me more on the scenery but i
still am drawn to drawing the people and
drawing the contradiction of you know
you're in a beautiful spot and it's
amazing and one should be full of awe
and reverence
and one is still annoyed at their
husband for not telling us where the
water was
[Music]
every part of the trail is beautiful but
there are some that are more beautiful
than others
tomorrow finally we're going to get out
of the trees a little bit and actually
get to see crater lake
crater lake is supposed to be just
gorgeous one of those sort of crown
jewels that you just get to walk along
you good with taking some time when we
get up there so i can draw
um get some coffee from the cafe get
some coffee eat some snacks eat some
snacks
along the trail
there are the people who are not hiking
the trail but who are helping out hikers
we call them trail angels
and one thing that they do for hikers is
provide trail magic any delightful thing
that sort of helps the hikers along
cheers
all the way to california man we were
thankful for them
no hiker i know has ever turned down a
cold
beer we come across this imaging trail
magic and i'm like oh unlabeled weird
thing you add water to
let's find out what it is
during a cartoon about a life
experiences which is what i'm doing on
the trail you are the architect of the
experience and the memory
i mean a trip like this is such a
extended metaphor which escapes no one
right you're going on the physical
journey and you're also going on the
internal journey i think we're almost
there
[Music]
nice nice
could we jump in it
yeah there's the trail down oh
to nice to really interesting ideas you
have to let time
not dictate you you have to have a
certain amount of freedom
[Music]
it's beautiful and it's very simple your
only goal is to move forward every day
i've just gotten to the point where
drawing is part of the way i interact
with the world and how i think through
my own experiences
being awakened alive every day makes me
want to interact with a piece of paper
also
and i've just put myself in the most
beautiful place i can imagine
that's kind of the goal is to have as
much of this as possible
this is the great shake-up that then i
get to digest for a long time
i think after i'm off the trail i'll
look through everything that i've done
and sort of decide where i want it to
live
so that it can have a life of its own
outside of my sketchbook
i'm looking forward to getting back into
my routine
do that more
practiced discovery
i bet after this trip i'll be stationed
for at least a couple months
i bet it'll be a little while before i
start pestering evan about our next
adventure
[Music]
[Music]
you